in a way because I'm not thankful to the
person who did this I am thankful that
it happened now and now I get to be free
beauty blogger nikkietutorials sat down
with Ellen DeGeneres on Wednesday just
that finish building I cannot I couldn't
wait for you guys to see Oh her first
interview since coming out as
transgender when I was younger I was
born in the wrong body which means that
I am transgender
I remember uploading the video I was
like I could do it and I started crying
Nicki posted the 17 minute long video on
YouTube last week after being
blackmailed he was not okay with the
fact that I was lying and wanted to
expose that so he had a very pressuring
tone of voice and he was like if we
don't get an answer by tomorrow it's out
and I feel like his entire goal was with
this to destroy my life a plot twist
that didn't happen the video has more
than 32 million views and celebs have
been freezing the social media star for
her bravery the incredible amount of
love and support and warmth means so
much to me
ariana grande commented with these
emojis on Nicki's Instagram another
singer Kim Petrus tweeted melted my
whole heart honestly but it was the
support from her fiance Dylan that got
her through it all my fiance Dylan was
right next to him he was like you can do
it you can do it so he really pushed me
to post it even though Nicki's not happy
about what pushed her to do it the
beauty guru is thankful in hopes to
inspire others I want to take this
opportunity to hopefully inspire a lot
of transgender people out there and even
when you're starting later on in your
journey that we need to accept that and
we have a feeling this is only the
beginning if the makeup artist is headed
to the shorties
if the stink
get any crazier apparently I am
nominated for youtuber of the year at
the Shorty Awards
I don't even know what to say
[Music]